yeah welcome to this video cg 2000 and
what kind of that looks good it's not
Indonesia it is singapore okay kind of
similar to Indonesia that flag so we got
the NIMS Oh probably and I can't go for
my slightly unsound samish but the Jack
gives entertaining games quite often so
let's accept the lower level of
soundness for some fun yeah it's
remarkable that quite a lot of players
go for go for this which is really not a
great setup for luck it's very very
passive
I'm happily playing g-form soonish
the only way really go okay preparing a
g4 is to do it aggressively with some
night f4 pawn sacrifice or something
like that if you just stay snow I don't
believe it or maybe a five or something
like that f5 takes before something
drastic that might not be really working
but if he accepts g4 and the retreat of
the night it would be pretty awful
yeah so he goes for that it shows good
understanding that he has to do
something drastic ok so anyway i think i
will take and King f to check before i
will get at least i don't see how he
keeps it
now I'm already a pawn up and so weds an
interesting move look you one maybe it's
this an idea I can take and play 95
hmm I can also i can also just take it
run I mean taking on c3 this is not
necessarily helping him that much it's
just to check their on defiance not not
that much more I was thinking at least
it's take 26
okay okay that I have to take root cakes
I will probably play rookie won rookie
one Queenie one Queen d3 that's made
only eight so i think i can use that
little tactic
yeah Bishop d7 maybe I'm just
don't really see a better move on add
this one okay let's let's take things f5
Creech egg so what is this is just one
pawn huh it's not more green here yeah
maybe Queen f4 pretty for tiny as a
checker that that I should have seen
oh it's a bit awkward
it's not not a big problem actually in
that check check can go to g3 maybe I
should have flicked in that check on e6
with hindsight he goes there anyway so
Queen g6 maybe or queen f4 and then I am
blundering stuff wow wow my rock let's
not do that keep the rook not give the
rook away that is probably not a bad
move
just d6 d7 and so on and I have rookie
form giving that look a stable square do
I have to do it now I can't start with
this right or to see if any no it
doesn't have a tactic can start with
that
it doesn't have a single check against
my king that's very very helpful stare
anyway
I need anything to play for checkmate
here maybe this age 5 rupee g6
it doesn't have many moves in any case
Quincy seven is a move instincts
probably not the best move now if I go
rook g6
I the 70s a check
it's not completely sure what the best
way to players Queen F sine threads rook
age six mate thats a good idea I think
don't really know what is doing against
it King age eight but then I have the
check there and d7 at the end that
should win
hmm or that
check check check g7 he's got that check
on g5 check start with this Queen d5 may
be alrigh again that's not so clear
amazing check check
check
no check now I think
head looks like a win d 7
check check check Wow check check that's
putting up some stiff resistance here
check black forfeits on time okay yeah
probably as usual I made it a little
more difficult than then it should have
been yeah that's an interesting position
you he went f5 that radical move that
has suggested and no night afore i was i
was thinking efore maybe is an idea like
this and 95 i know it it sacrifices two
pawns but it also yeah makes the whole
position completely messy sorry it's not
really working but check this is this i
really don't believe i think i should be
much better in this position well always
one point something for the engine this
is good checklist as good as well yeah
and it gives me a complete win here
rookie is six it's better than diesel
that also is classified okay again
rookie six here and now we're just queen
bee seven yeah that's a very simple
solution it's okay Queen f7 wins and now
d 7 is better i am k DD seven is very
strongly here Queen takes I have Roo
gauge six that's the major again check
and route takes check this check made so
we cannot take this is check irritated
me but I really can just play this
again check but i think what i did this
win as well it just said it was
irritating and of course you had to
check those checks two three check check
check yeah so i didn'ti didn't screw it
up whoo that's good thanks for watching